every year
more than 100 countries send six of
their brightest teenagers
or the occasional prepubescent prodigy
to represent them at the international
math olympiad
commonly known as the imo considering
that each country has its own elaborate
system of contests
leading to their choice of six
representatives the imo stands as the
culminating symbol for the surprisingly
expansive and wonderful world that is
contest math
the contest itself is essentially a test
split over
two days with three questions given over
four and a half hours each day
the questions are all proofs meaning you
don't simply find some numerical answer
you have to discover and articulate a
rigorous line of reasoning to answer
each difficult question
and then each one is scored on a scale
from zero up to seven
of interest to you and me today is the
one from 2011
with 563 total participants representing
101 countries
i know what you're thinking and the
answer is yes
those do all happen to be prime numbers
but that's not why this test was
interesting
out of all these prime problem solvers
only one of them lisa sauerman from
germany
got a perfect score and the only thing
standing between the next two runners-up
that year and a perfect score
was problem number two and this problem
is
beautiful and despite evading many of
the world's best mathematicians of their
age
the solution is something that anyone
watching this video can understand
so let's begin by reading through it
carefully
let s be a finite set of at least two
points on the plane
okay so as you read the question it's
often helpful to start drawing an
example for yourself
assume that no three points of s are
co-linear
in other words you never have three
points lining up so you can probably
predict that the problem's gonna involve
drawing lines in some way that three
points on one line would mess things up
a windmill is a process that starts with
a line l
going through a single point p in s the
line rotates clockwise around the pivot
p
until the first time that that line
meets some other point belonging to s
and again while reading it's helpful to
draw out an example
so we've got this line that's pivoting
around some point until it hits another
this point q takes over as the new pivot
and the line now rotates clockwise about
q until it next meets a point of s this
process continues
indefinitely all right that's kind of
fun
we keep rotating and changing the pivot
and you can see why they call it a
windmill process
and you can also see why they specified
that no three points lie on one line
you wouldn't want to run into the
ambiguity where you don't know which
pivot to switch to
okay so with all the setup what's the
question
show that we can choose a point p in s
and a line
l going through p such that the
resulting windmill
uses each point of s as a pivot
infinitely many times
alright depending on your tolerance of
puzzles for puzzle sake
you might wonder why would anyone care
about such a question
there's a very good reason in fact i
would argue that the act of solving this
will make you better at math and related
fields
and i'll explain why once you've seen
the solution but certainly on the
surface
it feels disconnected from other parts
of math i mean you look at other
olympiad problems and they often involve
some function to analyze or
a numerical pattern to deduce maybe a
difficult counting setup or an elaborate
geometric construction
but problem two it's an unusually pure
puzzle
and in some ways that's its charm
proving that some initial condition
will result in this windmill hitting all
the points infinitely many times
well that doesn't test your knowledge of
a particular theorem
it tests if you can find a clever
perspective
but that blade cuts both ways without
resting on an existing result from math
what could possibly prepare someone to
study for something like this
and in fact that brings us to the second
unusual thing about this problem
based on the results i'm guessing that
it turned out to be much harder than the
contest organizers expected
you see typically the three problems
each day are supposed to get
progressively harder
they're all hard of course it's the imo
but problems one and four
they should be doable problems two and
five they're challenging
and problems three and six well they can
be brutal
but take a look at how many of our 563
participants that year
got perfect scores on each of the
problems
only 22 of them got full marks for
question number two
by contrast 170 got a perfect score on
problem 5
which is supposed to be about the same
difficulty and more than twice as many
got a perfect score for problem 3
which is supposed to be harder some of
you might notice that only six students
got full points for problem six that
year
so by some measure that was the hardest
problem on the test
in fact the way i introduced things
earlier was a little disingenuous
the full data would suggest that problem
six was the real clincher
but what's strange is that if you look
at the results of those six students who
solved this hardest problem
all of whom are clearly phenomenal
world-class problem solvers
this windmill puzzle evaded 5 out of 6
of them
but again this problem is not hard
because of the background knowledge it
demands
it asks only for insight so how do you
approach something like this
the first step with any puzzle is to
simply play around with it and get a
feel for it
and it's always good to start simple and
slowly get more complicated from there
the simplest case would be two points
where the line trades off between each
point
and that works well enough adding a
third point it's pretty clear that the
line will just rotate around them
it might not be entirely clear how you
would phrase this as a rigorous proof
yet
but right now we're just getting a feel
for things the fourth point is where it
gets interesting
in some places your windmill will go
around the four points just like it did
with the triangle
but if we put it inside that triangle it
looks like our windmill never hits it
looking back at the problem it's asking
you to show that for some starting
position of the line
not any position the process will hit
all the points infinitely many times
so for an example like this if you start
with the line going through that
troublesome middle point
what happens and again at this point
we're just playing around perhaps moving
your pencil among dots that you've drawn
on a piece of scratch paper you want to
believe a result before you try too hard
to prove it
here you'd see that your windmill does
indeed bounce off of all of the points
as it goes through a cycle
and it ends up back where it started the
worry you might have
is that in some large sets of points
where some are kind of inside the others
you might be able to start off on the
inside but maybe something about this
windmill process
takes the line to the outside where as
time goes on to infinity it'll be
blocked
off from those inner points
if you play around and mind you it can
take some time to draw out many examples
and think this through
you would notice that when the line
starts off passing through the middle of
the points
it tends to stay there
it never seems to venture off to the
outside
but can you guarantee that this will
always happen or
rather can you first make this idea of
starting in the middle
a little bit more rigorous and from
there prove that all the points will be
hit infinitely many times
as a general problem-solving tip
whenever you have a vague idea that
feels productive
you should of course find a way to be
more exact about what you're saying
but preferably put numbers to it and
then see if you can ask questions about
those numbers
in our example one way to formalize this
idea of a middle
is to count how many points are on
either side of the line
if you give the line some orientation
you can reasonably talk about a left
half
say coloring all the points of the left
blue and a right half
say coloring all the points on the right
brown and what it means for a line to be
in the middle
is that there are as many blue points as
there are brown points
for the moment let's say that the total
number of points is an odd number
and the point that the line passes
through is colored white sort of a
neutral color so for example if there
were 11 points
you would have five blue ones on the
left five brown ones on the right
and the single white point as the pivot
the case with an even number of points
will be similar just slightly less
symmetric
what this gives us is a new question to
ask what happens
to the number of blue points and brown
points as the process plays out
in the example on screen now you might
notice it's always
5 and 5 never changing playing around
with other examples
you would find that the same is true
take a moment to pause right now
and see if you can think through why
exactly that would happen
why would these numbers not change
well the key is to think through what
happens as the line
changes its pivot having given the line
in orientation
we can talk reasonably about which half
is above the pivot
and which one is below if the line hits
a blue point on its left
it must happen below the pivot so then
when it changes the pivot and continues
rotating clockwise a bit
that old pivot now above the new one
ends up to the left
meaning it ends up in the blue region
and entirely symmetrically when it hits
a brown point
it happens above the pivot meaning that
the old pivot ends up in the brown
region
so no matter what the number of points
on a given side of the line
that cannot change except for the
instances where the line's passing
through two points at once
when you lose a blue point you gain a
new one when you lose a brown point you
gain a new one
and that is our key insight number one
so why would this imply that the line
must hit every point
infinitely many times no matter what
weird set of points you could dream up
well the second key is to think about
letting this process go
until the line has turned 180 degrees
around
what that means is it's parallel to the
starting position
and because it has to remain the case
that half the points are on one side
and half the points are on the other it
must be passing through the same point
it started on
i mean think about it if it ended up on
some other point
it would change the number on a given
side
additionally since the line has rotated
halfway around
everything that was blue has become
brown and everything which was brown has
become blue
and the only way to change a color is if
you get hit by the line
so for our odd numbered case that means
that after a half rotation
the line is back where it started and
it's hit all of the other points
so as time moves forward it repeats this
exact set of motions over and over
hitting all of those points infinitely
many times
for the case with an even number of
points we need to alter this game
slightly
but only slightly to make it so that the
number of blues can equal the number of
browns
let's say that the pivot counts now as a
brown point so to define our initial
condition
we still say for a given angle of the
line select an initial point so that
half of the points are blue
all on the left and half of them are
brown now either meaning they're on the
right
or the pivot the same argument from
before
implies that after 180 degree turn
everything has swapped colors but this
time the line will be passing through a
different point after that first half
turn
specifically one that used to be blue
but
after another 180 degrees it has to be
passing through the one that it started
on
again the logic is that it's parallel to
its starting position
and if it was passing through any other
point the number of points on a given
side
would have to be different so once more
we have a cycle
which hits all of the points and which
ends in the same position where it
started
this time it takes 360 degrees but that
doesn't matter
as the cycle continues it'll hit all the
points infinitely many times
stepping back there are two important
lessons to take away from this puzzle
the first one social and the second one
mathematical
once you know this solution and if you
kind of ponder it a bit and turn it
around in your head a couple times
it's very easy to fool yourself into
thinking that the problem is easier than
it is
after all of course the number of points
on a given side stays constant
right of course that's a question you
would ask and of course when you start
in the middle every point will switch
sides after a half a turn but the
advantage of this problem coming from
the imo
is that we don't have to rest on
subjective statements we have the data
to show
it's a genuinely hard problem in that it
evaded many of the world's best students
who are demonstrably able to solve hard
problems
in math it is extremely hard to
empathize with what it feels like to not
understand something
i was discussing this video with a
former co-worker of mine from khan
academy
who worked a lot with people creating
math exercises and he pointed out that
across a wide variety of contributors
there's one constant nobody is able to
tell how difficult their exercises are
knowing when math is hard is way harder
than the math itself this is important
to keep in mind when teaching
but it's equally important to keep in
mind when being taught
on our windmill puzzle even if counting
the number of points on one side
seems obvious in hindsight you have to
ask
given the vast space of possible things
you might consider
why would anyone's mind turn to that
particular idea
this brings us to the mathematical
takeaway what ultimately led to the
solution
was finding something about the complex
system which stays constant
during this chaotic unfolding this is a
ubiquitous theme through math and
especially through physics
we're finding what's called an invariant
topologists do this when they count the
number of holes in a surface
physicists do this when they define the
ideas of energy and momentum
or in special relativity when they
define more abstract ideas like proper
time
as a student it's easy to take for
granted the definitions handed down to
you
but the more puzzles you solve where the
insight involves an invariant
the more you come to appreciate that
each one of these definitions
was once a clever discovery
terence tao one of the greatest modern
mathematicians and the world's youngest
imo medalist
wrote that mathematical problems or
puzzles are important to real
mathematics
like solving real-life problems just as
fables stories and anecdotes are
important to the young
in understanding real life sure these
kinds of puzzles are contrived but they
carry lessons relevant to useful
problems you may actually need to solve
one day
maybe it seems silly to liken this
windmill puzzle to a fairy tale
a mathematical aesop summarizing that
the moral of the story is to seek
quantities which stay constant but some
of you watching this
will one day face a problem where
finding an invariant reveals a slick
solution
and you might even look like a genius
for doing so if a made-up windmill
prepares you for a real problem
who cares that it's a fiction
[Music]
[Music]
you